welcome back the true news this is the
show where we usually try and have a
laugh at [__] YouTube drama and
don't take anything seriously but we
can't do that this week because things
have gotten very very serious another
death of a black man at the hands of a
white police officer has got all of
America saying enough is enough you trot
you trapped oh he's breathing right
there bro
like you don't think that what it is bro
you don't think nobody understands that
[__] right there bro I trained at the
Academy brought up some [__]
hey bro is he dead yeah he starts moving
after a while someone comes over and
checks his pulse and it's quite clear
he's like stop breathing stop talking
[__] red balloon the thing that's
really sad about it is that there's two
police officers there and one of them
just stands alongside another guy who's
clearly not following just as there's
forint all of ya the protocol of what
they should be doing that isn't even a
[__] hold that the teach in that at
least for the guys arms are behind his
back he is completely debilitated he
can't do anything back to you yeah
they're not in any danger if you want to
put body weight on his back like I've
seen some police officers do before like
still not great but like you know you're
not going to kill the guy you're putting
your body weight on his windpipe you
know so much has come out about this
Derrick Chauvin the entire police force
who employed this guy who allowed him to
continue going out whoever is in charge
or equally responsible because you can't
tell me you believe this guy was a sane
person these are all the issues that
this [__] had before eventually
the murder 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 15 before any discipline was handed
out no imagine in any job you [__] up
15 times to a point where people made
complaints about you and you get no
discipline what is a wart job in the
[__] world would that have happened
it took 15 times before he caught a
letter of reprimand and then another one
after that and then another one was no
discipline that's 18
only two times you get a letter the
guide was clearly a cycle and the police
force allowed us to carry on we don't
know what was going on here but let's be
honest the end result gives you a
[__] clue of what's likely in that
footprint Lirette yeah so I think this
is the really great thing about what
happens on the Internet at the moment is
the freedom of information means that
people can go out there and find out
more information about the people who
are doing wrong in these situations so
he's being represented by the same
lawyer who got the last dirty murder and
cop off it's not great look is it not
it's almost like an admittance of guilt
before you start idea what do we do lost
hope the girl food we're gonna need this
guy and Tom Kelly Tom Kelly was sat at
home after he saw this going my phone's
gonna ring at any moment he's looking at
really good give it a minute
give it her yeah hello yeah next on the
list
he shot ira luttrell Torres an unarmed
black 21 year old man in 2008 like
exactly what I said earlier this is in
his history
how on earth was this allowed to carry
on he was also one of the officers who
murdered way in reality no man who had
16 bullets in him I mean it doesn't take
16 does it you're either enjoying it or
you're reckless that's the point is it
goes back to excessive force yeah which
has clearly been a staple of his career
and we can take this piece of
information here at the 12 police
brutality complaints we're building a
good image of this guy and his boss knew
he had a psycho on his hands and you
just let them keep on going back over a
decade this was happening and then it
goes back to basically what Will Smith
said there is not more racism we're just
filming it now yeah and that's what was
happening people are now catching these
people do these things because they
can't the restaurant called Oh
Louisville rodeo George Cloyd works at
that restaurant the Soviet officers
Chauvin they were both bouncers at that
restaurant for 17 years so Sheldon he's
ordered when I heard that I was like
[__] me that blew me away though let's
be clear Bryan racists on a daily basis
exist alongside you alongside me and we
treat them as normal people because
racists don't walk around saying hey
racist good to meet you
they walk around saying hey
I'm George I'm Karen I'm blah blah blah
why would they want to go around
emitting that and then the moment that
these people get an opportunity to do
something someone else they take the
opportunity repeatedly assume it
repeatedly even when he knew the guy
it's not just black people this guy I'd
had to go Latino people and had to go
other minorities within the community so
it's not as if this is just black people
this effect this affects anyone who's a
minority and the point is at any one
point you could be the minority on
mastery this is a video from George
Floyd before he died I came in to use
the little [__] told me yeah Florida
your little truth man right there
because he could bust good I mean I knew
was crazy here to think of my age seeing
this here me nothing they could know
that this [__] bro no saying and like
have two young [__] shooting them
girls go home and they me shaking the
night but they don't short nobody
because you know they tough did a man
come on home man one day it's gonna be
your guard you going up when you're
going down you know saying that's gonna
be and it'll make this message spitting
image me [__] you right now George boy
is clearly a guy who is concerned with
his community the people around them and
all of the character references all the
people in new George B them famous be
them just you know normal friends on the
street all made an image of this guy
that is someone who cares about the
people around him and someone who's not
aggressive in that way who might have
problems in his own life but isn't the
kind of person that you need to restrain
in this way and that's why this is he
called the guy officer to the bitter end
he didn't wasn't disrespecting him like
you know in that way this is what George
is talking about in this video people
are doing things unconsciously without
knowing it in the black community white
people are doing things unconsciously
because the system is teaching them to
either be racist or to shoot people or
to do these things and now is the time
to stop thinking about those things now
is the time to step back and think am i
racist am i doing something bad what am
i doing there might be back in these
people up people like George clearly
cared about the people around them and
he ended up dead at the hands of a
police officer [__] sucks
so after George Floyd was pronounced
dead everyone was demanding action taken
against Derek shavon it just seemed like
it wasn't gonna happen it was all he's
been fired is that well thank you but if
we nicely got some [__] justice
around here because it always seems like
cops just get off with this whenever
this happens it's IRA's fire
Dyan enough this time this is happening
too often so protests started and then
riots started let's look at the protests
first that was a perfectly observed
protest but sadly probably wasn't going
to achieve much like the government had
walls of police officers outside of
Derek shawhans house like they were
protecting him does that not tell you
what the [__] is wrong with this
situation they're protecting the
murderer from the people demanding
justice chaos
became in the eyes of many necessary in
order to [__] force justice to be
dealt oh it's like if you're not gonna
listen to what we want and you're just
gonna protect your murderer we're going
to go [__] crazy now and I'm not
saying it's right because innocent
people get caught up in it you've got
business owners getting caught up in
this [__] and in you know people do
nothing but I understand the rage yeah
and this is not the first time let's not
forget this is millions of times has
happened now the stretch in America yeah
a lot of people saying this is using
language that the government and police
understand that was a woman sitting in a
car and the police have just thrown that
in there it got to a point where the
police were terrified so the police are
now making more mistakes than ever now I
call the mistakes they're just
deliberately being our souls to people
as well that's right so they're just
they taking that offensive now where
they're just hitting anyone who comes in
here and that's the difficulty here
because we know that not all police are
racist people but they are taking part
in something which has racism in it this
feels to the to the people like they are
defending in bunch over 100 outside of
us for a doll when you defend the racist
killer you become in the eyes of the
people complicit yeah and part of the
problem so they go [__] all you then I
imagine and this is the thing in in the
minds of many of the police men and
women who got up that morning as they're
putting their uniform on going for [__]
sake look at what you cause like to this
Derrick Chauvin fella they're probably
thinking you selfish to [__] you've
you've murdered someone and now we're
all frightened we're all watching our
back to go
men and women who did say enough to be
the good guys I've now got to go to work
and face this [__] because of that one
the reason these people are supposed to
sign up to be police men and women is to
go I'm gonna protect and serve the
people but when the people don't agree
with the [__] decisions by the
government who are doing it all assuit
themselves the police then become a
defense line of the government against
the people and that's the reality here
and that's what no one ever admits see
this [__] pisses me off whether it be
child killers in the UK who get renamed
rehomed reef up being identified and all
of that [__] and then you've got another
killer here who's being protected if you
do [__] up [__] why have I come see
you deserve our tax money shouldn't go
to protect them this [__] prick you
know why they're out there because his
bones would have been dangled through
that from a [__] lamppost you know
what I mean like they would have dropped
his [__] head off and played football
with it maybe that shouldn't happen
but maybe you shouldn't have [__]
killed the guy me like they they're
basically stopping real justice come
into the [__] front door they that's
the type of [__] we would have said I
would quite like to say that his head
being swished is that right though with
a person basketball yeah that's what
they're stopping you know when you say
killers in like when you say dictators
in Middle Eastern and they get [__]
like they're the the dead bodies are
like why step through the streets on
foot and everyone's like that's what we
would have send it that would have sent
a [__] message to the [__]
government this [__] will come to your
front door next time I like it when
people who think they're in power all of
a sudden are like oh [__] we tracked
them wrong we [__] up we actually
should have been a bit more respectful
of this community I also feel sorry for
the police officers who want to do their
job yeah who want to protect people and
you believe I tell you you've got a
choice though just because you sign on
that dotted line does not mean as a
police officer that you have to do
everything you're told to do so if you
go into work like that morning your
chief the guy who waved the 15 times
sorry the 18 times that he was being
brutal to people who didn't deserve it
most likely you got a choice to go you
know what are you all of this I see in
this common we all
has come with this practice if you want
me to understand outside his house how
about you [__] go and do it I'm gonna
actually go and do proper police work
and not protect this [__] murderer I
empathize with the ones out on the
street who are now trying to deal with
the riot because of this guy but when
you're standing outside his house
protecting them [__] you
I hope this sends a message to every
police officer in the whole [__]
world you never know who's watching you
never know who's recording you better
act right from now on because otherwise
this could be London this could be
anywhere and there could be outside of
your [__] house paying for blood
you have some people are laughing some
people are videotaping you all right
this is what's bizarre about this this
is CNN covering a protest attacking the
CNN building and they all just floors
above this happening is their symbolism
more for this absolutely the big
institutions the police inside them
people attacking what they see is the
problem misinformation and this I was
watching some wanted me to comment about
CNN and why they would pick CNN and it's
like these guys are part of a huge
amount of scare mongering of the amp the
[__] out of coronavirus and every other
situation to make people as terrified as
possible because the more emotion people
feel when watching your show the more
likely they are to carry on watching and
it's like now it's at your front door
but but what you did now that the scared
ones are you [__] I don't have
much sympathy but I do have simply this
woman I mean this was just ridiculous
I've seen this the opposite of that is
that then the police are suddenly
shooting at a reporter she's behind the
lighting apparently so she's within our
rights to be there this guy who come
where's the guy with the gun yeah there
is no there he is right I don't quite
understand he can clearly see she's a
reporter you can clearly see that she's
got a camera over Zordon oh yeah this is
what happens when you have a president
who calls the press the enemy because
let's face it there are people in the
police force there are people in any
line of work with power who enjoy the
power who enjoy enforcing it on other
people and when you have a dicker
president who can't back up his own
media then that's what you get so this
is a police precinct that's been set on
fire racism in modern society relies on
something called soft power people
taking part and people saying let's just
tell this guy that he's a bit racist and
see if he changes what the police
officer did was hard power where you
murder someone and hard power gets
responded to with hard power people
start setting things on fire they start
responding with aggression because they
begin to believe that the only thing the
police will listening to is aggression
it's difficult to know how to handle
this because a few years before this
Obama a previous president of the states
who had a lot of respect on I think both
sides of the aisle said that looters
should also be treated as criminals you
have to as the president say that would
be favor them yeah like the minute you
condone that you're allowing chaos their
job now is to swap this down as quick as
they can and and go all right you've
made your point now we'll do what you
want but can you just stop the [__]
rip and the whole [__] plays off
flipside of that maybe the best place to
deliver that is not through 240
characters or less like he his press
officer walks in and goes so we need you
to deliver a message you know I'm right
on it it's like you just could you'd
stop I've sent the tweet I've sent the
tweet and everyone goes whoa Donald
maybe maybe don't do that and he goes
already sentence these thugs or dis
honoring the memory of George Floyd and
I won't let it happen
this isn't about George Floyd alone this
is about the thousand other black men
who we've seen killed by white police
officers this has happened so many
[__] times now this is not just about
George Floyd and so what Donald Trump
thinks the best thing to do is to
threaten I know if there's one thing
that this what are going to respond to
you right now it's good right maybe the
threat I had guarantee there was a
general in the room who went we could
send the military answer and he goes
love it work on that work on that I'm
just spitballing I'm just spitballing we
could launch them into space good
anything else let's just ignore it sir
I'll tweet all of this Twitter actually
put a disclaimer on his first tweet
which was the when the looting starts
the shooting starts now
that Twitter ruled was glorifying
violence good rap lyric yeah now a lot
of people weren't aware of where that
reference allegedly comes from the
phrase was originally used by a ma'am
Miami police chief who was widely
condemned by civil rights groups
good guys viola yeah when you're
thinking of quotes to you
I like the idea that Donald Trump
sitting around he goes it's the time to
use that quote and his advisor goes
maybe we'll just go could we explain
what about Martin Luther King he then
sort of threatens that if this doesn't
stop the military will begin to go and
that I love the [__] you the end of a
concept this is the weirdest year of
history of our like this is this is not
[Music]
it seems if this guy is just one into a
metal workshop here and two guys are
just getting their hammer I did think of
they had burn us they would have gotten
through that way quicker way right yeah
I would have gotten through that in two
seconds really yeah it feels like part
of this is the coronavirus already had
people really frustrated and in town
yeah like there's so much emotion going
on right now in the world where people
are not happy and then saying that just
evolved such a visceral reaction I'm not
sitting here saying that the coronavirus
has you know meant that people have done
this I'm just saying that emotionally
people were already in a worse place
than what they would have been and maybe
that's then heightened the reaction
again mmm AB see they feel trapped they
feel control is such a [__] like oh
[__] this [__] here CNN footage of the
crew that's reporting on the riots being
arrested wherever you'd want us we won't
we will go we were just getting out of
your way when you're advancing through
the intersection so just let us know man
we got you kind of worries me is how
readily the police had all of this
available there's so many police dressed
in riot gear I'm like did you guys know
this how come we took so long for us to
get like PE the right guys just sat in
the back we've got no more everyone
either even the protesters could have
had some dude let's make this a fair
fight all right well you care for all
our masks tricky gas masks very easy it
is ironic yeah and in a perfect solution
yeah would've actually yeah none of
these guys are getting Corona and you
local police showed up at the fire
department or with the fire department I
should say on that building we showed
you those burning this is among the
State Patrol they saw a black man they
instantly headed towards in Padang I
mean he has a microphone and I thought
he was a robber arrest that man credit
to this guy
whilst he's got the hand of a policeman
on
arms still trying to report some people
are dedicated to the craft on there I
mean that awareness in the moment must
be crazy speaking really well hear you
speaking so calmly and getting the
message across despite being surrounded
by hundreds of police with weapons yeah
I'm sorry okay do you I am under arrest
sir why am i under arrest
what for though you have to tell us is
it I'm arresting you on suspicion of
being this fine they're just like bro
we're doing what we want though yeah
we're doing what we want if you're just
tuning in you are watching our
correspondent Omar Jimenez being
arrested by state police in Minnesota
we're not sure why this is America you
expect Brian Heights by saying this is
America it's like White's going oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah but that music video and
not that cherish convener was the first
to [__] say but like I mean Tupac
called a lot of this [__] 25 years
ago just felt very in the moment didn't
it no effect at that time is it's the
music video come to life now even more
bizarre yeah in the music alright the
time felt extreme yet oh now
underselling yeah the cops look at that
and they went hold our beer perfect for
Kim hell why they still beating up this
I don't know I don't know eating him oh
there's a female officer that gets in
here and loves it you're not trying to
arrest someone here you're just beating
the [__] he's having a block party I
was under the impression the whole point
of taking someone down to the ground was
trying to he's just trying to cause
maximum damage yeah what's the point in
that
what is it achieve especially when you
know there are people with cameras there
that's what I find crazy about this
they're wearing the face mask for
coronavirus I'm pretty sure you're
breaking the to me to rule it
yeah when you're all over him with a
foot band stick in his face look I need
a bigger baton two meter one there's
also a few policemen who are basically
dressed as members so this has been
highlighted more and more undercover
cops pausing this protesters so he's
definitely you know carrying a weapon
he's giving himself away very yeah so I
know what I'll do this will trick him
I'll wear some cargo yeah I'll wear
khaki shorts yeah no one will be any the
wiser
like well you're carrying a gun in broad
daylight
you know you are in a backwards cap I
mean it's a giveaway to European so at
that point isn't it it's like oh hello
fellow protesters so heard of any
illegal activity going on in the area
and they were like what sorry I would
love to smoke some drugs right now as a
normal guy one of the oldest tricks in
the book from a protest standpoint for
the police to get rid of a peaceful
protest is they dress up like protesters
they go and infiltrate and then at some
point they start smashing something up
or getting violent or causing issues so
that then the police have the right by
law to come in and be physican right
this might seem to some of you guys like
some crazy conspiracy theory talk this
is one of the oldest tricks in the book
it is used almost every single [__]
time you see the problem of that is is
not just the fact that he put his hands
on her but her head klappas off the
floor he back the cause like a death
let's just say this in real time that
has not been known to kill people before
like the disregard for human life now
like 150 sizes this is it's an us and
them mentality and as much as I get that
the cops are all scared and the start of
lead that kill kill I had an iPhone I
anything like that like this just it's
getting to a point where the people who
are supposed to be looking after the
community are more crazy than a lot of
the crazies out there who they skate off
they've gone mental here
oh [__] there are politically driven
looters who are trying to make
statements by attacking police buildings
then there are the idiots who go free
[__] like with the police you got them
turning on the wrong people and being
overly forceful the exact same thing is
happening on the other side especially
in a time when a lot of people are
already going to be financially
struggling just more I think that proves
that the system at the top-down not
supposed to govern the people that's
supposed to govern the police officers
is totally [__] yet no one's listening
to anyone at the policeman celebrating
with this woman who's twerking here or
what's going a kind of thing so yeah
that's part of the life to a piece
that's I mean I mean if there's one
thing that can stop a lord of Angry Men
in their trucks it's a huge booty shake
and it's a big bottom it's a real whoa
what we fighting over this yeah there's
a bum there that we can all look at Moo
this is the weirdest movie ever none of
this feels real if this was in a movie
and you're like yeah there was a riot
going on and everyone's fighting each
other police and then of girls just work
that's not realistic writing half this
stuff that happens you go yeah that
wouldn't happen in a real in a script
this is important how one of the riots
started
[Applause]
and that is exactly how I'd expected to
starting with a policeman lashing out
and I get like urine you're in the
policeman's face like but that's way
restrain calmness that needs to be
taught from day one the fact that he
couldn't just keep calm they're like
it's caused brutality for all that's
part of your training must be they can't
no longer depend on us like they say
they're gonna do so this is what you get
and though it's not going in today I
can't tell you trying anymore I don't
know it is going weird but it's what you
are to start we're not the ones that's
telling us you're killing us we can't
make it tight if the kid was begging for
police to back down we've got examples
here of an undercover cop clearly
stoking the fire to make it worse so
that police can be more brutal so that's
quite a peaceful protest review at that
point yeah and then all of a sudden
confirmed caught that while you're there
sending out a police officer to smash
the place up when everyone's being
peaceful so exactly like I said they
need that to happen in order for them to
then be enforcers and then they've got
all the justification they want no this
was fought but this reporter was caught
playing fake gun shots on his cell phone
at the Minneapolis protest and then
blamed it on black people you didn't not
be a problem I know when I go out I
think I'll take my gun shot video with
me just in case I might go [__] crazy
is this now from a galaxy far far away
john-boy Jaeger sent this from the top
I'm totally on board with him we're in
you'll see now you just start a video
yeah hey it raised that we should have
started with that yes I'm going to feel
like we've been a bit ambiguous so far
yeah can we just clarify what he said
anyone who's sort of mid-level hates
racism you've got to be suspicious of
that [__] because any reason halfway
tolerant I'm questioning yeah exactly if
you're going well some of them I have a
point don't go down that route because
they don't all right would you shower I
assess there's unsub me that in the
comment it's like a smoker isn't it you
just don't kiss him
with more people that come through and
try to make these situations what
they're not come submit right the fact
that you started robbing I think you
have in Vaseline I've got chopped yeah
middle of a rut about races I was like
this is real just probably normal I love
that I'd love it if at the top it just
is branded as I was watching this I
thought this guy would make a sick
podcast because I don't know if you're
away he's been the head of quite an
interesting life yeah he grew up in
England
do you remember I was I think was the
murder of the Molalla to Haley he was a
rut like right course around that yeah I
think he was friends with the kid by
bringing that up what I'm trying to say
is this guy hasn't just had an easy
route to Hollywood he's been in real
life situations where he's had tragedy
he's qualified to speak on this a black
man was just murdered in cold blood in
the streets stateside again while saying
that he can't breathe that's a
continuous cycle going on and although I
don't live in the States but I'm black
so I say again
[__] you racist white people strong
message you know the crazy thing about
that some people thought he should have
been worried for saying that because he
might get dropped from films as if we
should be trying to cater films to
racists I guess the point is racist do
so exist they do still go and watch
films the problem should not be to take
the actor out the film the problem
should be to tell the rest is people
going to watch the film maybe consider
your views a little bit you shouldn't
have to worry for saying [__] racists
the guy was the one of the lead roles in
a Disney movie sort of hear that come
out of his mouth is is has impact and it
should have impact and that's healthy
that's gonna make people who idolized
Star Wars actors who are young people
realise what side is your [__] field
there it days actually a good point
O'Brien because there will be young
racists and I'm not I'm not being funny
or young impressionable people who could
go down that road without i right yeah
and they might see this and go maybe I
won't be racist it will have an impact
yeah you'll be upset with obi-wan Kenobi
or whatever his name is I said what I
said I've got [__] like it go suck a
dick I think that might be partly what
people are pointing out in regards to
the way delivered the message and art
that he was a lead actor in a Disney
movie and then all of a sudden you're on
an island go suck a dick
there's a time and a place to get
serious and I think we pick the right
moment if you can't explain to your kids
why one of their favorite actors is
angry right now and you're worried about
your kids hearing about sucking dick or
whatever cuz it might upset them maybe
consider how upset some people are about
not being able to go out without
worrying that you might get killed so
the great thing to go along with that is
that then a lot of major black figures
in the community from basketball from
acting from activism all different sides
came out and started to speak publicly
in a very healthy discourse rather than
through violence or things I think it
needed some big people like that a
stand-up and they were bought together
from a friend of George Floyd who also
happens to be an NBA player who is
called Steven Jackson who some people
from back in the day will know is
basically one of the baddest
[__] in basketball if you were
gonna fight this is the first guy that
will be there with you what he says has
a lot of power I think I'm proud yeah
and then Jamie Foxx steps forward makes
very powerful speech you guys get a
chance please find circle of mothers
where there's a hundred two hundred
cases like this that don't get the
visibility and don't get the cams and
it's strong women Sabrina right now
Trayvon's mom who's running for a
commissioner to try to do something
different well Jamie said that's key
there is that not all of these things
get the same press coverage so while
this might be new news to some people
this is old news to other people feels
like [__] Groundhog Day
correct he said there are hundreds of
these kind of cases and I think that's
what's important to hear from watching
this makes you also question it feels
like hundreds of these have been videoed
how many of these on video then there
was a bit of kick back against Lil Wayne
I mean what he said he's not the first
political speaker you'd like him he's
not to PUC but he is seen weirdly
because he's rapper as opposed to people
I you say these are is one of the
biggest names isn't here we have to stab
you in different ways such a broad view
meaning we have to stop placing the
blame on the whole the whole force in
the whole
by such a certain or certain race
everybody would have bad and that we
have to actually we have to get get into
who that person is and if we want to
place the blame on anybody it should be
ourselves we're not going more than
where we think we're going look at one
point I was like okay so you're saying
blame that exact police officer not the
entire police Hoss but it is an
interesting point in it that there may
be some fairness and the halfway at that
point he totally changed his course and
says we have to blame ourselves what
where's he going with this I'm wondering
did the reason why people do that is
because I mean what else am I gonna do
after that really week we some some
people put a tweet out and they think
they did something that's actually a
very good point and a lot of people
tweeting right now I thought twice
before tweeting about it because I
thought well what else are you gonna do
Lawrence what the what else are you
gonna say about it are you gonna hat do
anything of consequence realistically
I'm not but I care about it and I think
Lil Wayne's right like maybe while we
are busy condemning all these people and
we're busy condemning the rights and
those kind of things a lot of people do
just sit back and do very little it
doesn't make them wrong you can point
something out and still be alright about
that some people don't want to put their
[__] freedom on the lane or there are
necessarily as corvid 19 has proven
self-preservation before everything if
Corvin matings taught us anything
everyone's acting like we're all indoors
right now because we care about the
people at risk no the majority of people
are indoors because they're frightened
for themselves that's the same reason
people don't want to [__] go out with
a bat in their hand and smash up [__]
and take the police on like not everyone
can do that that's why many of these
people aren't twenty-year-old men who
are fearless and [__] testosterone
pumped in through their veins and like
I'm ready you know what I mean but not
everyone's got that in their the plus
side is this policeman has been arrested
but for third-degree murder so this is
basically the easiest to prove but also
the least punished in America everyone
knows what this is it's not quite the
same in the UK but
first-degree murder premeditated plans
prior to act so basically he had to plan
to do this you can't really nail them on
that it'll be very difficult to do that
second-degree murder intention to murder
victim but did not plan it private a lot
of people arguing that could be I think
that that should be at least what is
charge yeah and then third degree murder
she's intentionally harming someone but
not expecting the victim to die the guy
who's literally crying out for 9 [__]
men
like I can't breathe at what point can
you be held accountable for that he gave
you all the warning in the world and you
carried on kept saying the same thing
same thing over and over and over I
don't you know they're gonna go as
lenient as possible on it and you know
they're gonna give him the absolute
special treatment he is not gonna be in
a block full of killers they're not
gonna put him with everyone else he's
gonna be protected at all costs hi Deena
just Foxx's off that like really uh you
should be threat fed at the bus that
lions at this point no this guy was on
the Joe Rogan podcast few ohms he's
wrapped it in outcast albums he's
wrapped with jay-z yeah this guy is an
influencer of the best minds I didn't
want to come and I don't be here I'm the
son of an Atlanta City police officer my
cousin is in last sheet of police
officer and my other cousin East Point
police officer and I got a lot of love
and respect for police officers down to
the original eight police officers in
Atlanta that even acted becoming police
had to dress in a YMCA because white
officers didn't want to get dressed wit
knickers dot a Lordan powerful [__]
started with speech this man is related
to police officers but he is proven he's
educated about the start in the past of
what people have gone through so you
already know before he even goes into
this that there's some sense gonna be
spoken Australian I'm mad
as Hale I woke up wanting to see the
world burn down yesterday but it's hired
see black being died he casually put his
knee on a human beings neck for nine
minutes as he died like a zebra in the
clutch of a lion's jaw and we watch it
like murder porn over and over again so
that's why children are burning to the
ground they don't know what else to do
and it is a responsibility of us to make
this better
right now we don't want to see one
officer charge we want to see four
officers prosecuted and sentenced so we
didn't need to do this video you know
we're not gonna make anyone
of this this is not sponsored this
YouTube will shut the [__] down so quick
have you got an ad it's going to YouTube
trust me thought we felt the need to
talk about this to cover this because it
is such an important subject and
hopefully some of the younger people out
there who do watch our stuff feel a bit
more informed on the situation
yeah maybe you can get in the comments
let us know what you guys think as well
I start a good conversation for me
personally I just feel like the root of
racism kind of goes back to human nature
and some people they're frightened of
difference in at an early age
if that isn't educated and our family's
educated us and said well actually it's
okay like people have different skin
colors it's not a big deal they're
exactly the same as me in you and then
other families don't do that and they
encourage the fear and they turn that
fear into hair in some states in America
are these families are not that far
removed from families who owned slaves
like slavery is not that long ago in
some states and I mean like a couple of
generations even and it's going to take
a [__] ton of time before we get
everyone on the same page realizing how
ridiculous it is to care about someone's
skin color
this sort of thing unfortunately is
going to be a byproduct of getting there
we'll keep reporting on this on true
news hopefully you enjoyed this video
and feel as strongly as we do about it
hit the subscribe button and we'll see
ya